as we all know at the end of Avengers
endgame
Iron Man made the ultimate sacrifice
sacrificing his life to save the entire
universe this of course would
effectively end Tony Stark's time in the
MCU as far as the future of the MCS
timeline goes there is no longer a Tony
Stark in the MCU how's it going
everybody it's Warren and the fact that
Iron Man is no longer in the MCU is
something that fans are just really
upset about
and although fans want Robert Downey jr.
--zz Tony Stark back in the MCU Marvel
is not going to undo Tony Stark's death
because it will undo the significance of
it in Avengers endgame but there still
is hope for Iron Man to return in the
MCU and I am NOT talking about during
Black Widow there is a chance that he
could return in a future Avengers movie
I'll explain everything you need to know
in this video but real quick if you'd
like a chance to win an Xbox one or a
ps4 be sure to subscribe to my channel
and leave a like and a comment down
below so you can enter my giveaway so
yesterday I did a video talking about
what is most likely going to be the next
huge crossover event for the MCU and it
will be probably the biggest crossover
event that anybody has ever seen it will
be bigger than Avengers end game this is
because the next big crossover event is
most likely going to have the Avengers
the x-men the Fantastic Four and
villains like Doctor Doom and Galactus
I'm talking about
Avengers secret wars battle world and
during this event Robert Downey jr. iron
man could make an appearance the battle
world event is one of the biggest events
in Marvel Comics and as I mentioned it
has a ton of characters in it ranging
from The Avengers to Spider Man to the
Fantastic Four the x-men Doctor Strange
and god-emperor dooms just to name a few
and what the batter will the vent is is
essentially the destruction of the
multiverse so in the comics there is a
multiverse there are multiple different
realities and universes that exist and
they all have different versions of
different characters spider-man into the
spider verse was the perfect example in
each universe there was a Spider Man but
it was a different person and in the
battle world event they all end up
colliding into one universe each
individual earth from each individual
universe ends up colliding into each
other and what happens is when all of
these earths end up colliding into each
other they end up
forming one planet and this is called
the battle world now the result of each
earth colliding into each other and
forming one world that means that all of
the different multiverse characters are
now in one place there is essentially no
longer a multiverse but each character
that was on each individual earth are
now in the same place on one planet the
battle world which is just in one
universe so what ends up happening is we
have multiple versions of the same
character in one place so there will be
many different versions of Spider Man
many different versions of black panther
many different versions of Doctor
Strange and there will be many different
versions of Iron Man this is where we
could see Tony Stark's show up again in
the MCU now of course it won't be the
Tony Stark from our main earth universe
but it could be a Tony Stark played by
Robert Downey jr. this would be the
perfect time for Marvel to bring back
Robert Downey jr. for a quick cameo in
an actual Avengers film in the future
Marvel has already shown that they're
not against bringing back Robert Downey
jr. in the MCU as Iron Man as we have
just found out that he is going to be in
the Black Widow movie now of course this
is set in the past so it doesn't undo
his death and Avengers in game but
battleworld won't undo his death either
it will just be a different version of
Tony Stark but it will be Tony Stark and
it could be played by Robert Downey jr.
so this is how we could see Iron Man
return to the MCU in a future Avengers
film but let me know what you think
about this would you like to see a quick
cameo by Robert Downey jr. playing Tony
Stark slash Iron Man in the MCU in a
future Avengers film even if it's a
different version of Iron Man let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and again don't forget to
subscribe to my channel and leave a like
so you can enter my giveaway for your
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
if you'd like a chance to win a Nintendo
switch be sure to follow me on Twitter
and click the link in the description
down below as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof